quello di chi ragazzi venuti questo
nuovo video sono felice ma sigla del
team rocket quella dei pokémon
esageriamo tornati sull'episodio di the
forest con leonardo de carli secondo
episodio eravamo rimasti e ci stavano a
fan culo così i mostri nella caverna
riprendiamo abbia attirato sul fuoco che
di fatto il salto di porca [ __ ] addio
di calci ma possiamo fare mica e vabbè
lega scappa scappa scappa zio aspetta
rimane diano fuoco la tanto salta ci
brucia all'inferno prendi tu non ce
l'hai la moto
oddio capraia tutti uno zio che brutta
cosa la bastarda mamma stato non è nono
nei versi italiani ma la sua morto è
arrivato io non ci credo sto morì
anch'io cioè quando lo attaccavano gli
facevo da
minchia sì vabbé ma imposti di casa
aprite il boss del gioco cioè i brividi
ma che bello quando muore che c'è un
indigeno ti mangiano fantastico che
vorrei spronati a tu sei diverso da
prima guardami adesso tu sei abdul visto
mai come cia le braccia questa qua
federale è un poco storto oddio se così
marcati via san salvo lo faro e jacquard
drago guarda bellissima staccionata che
vola e non ha infatti l'ho notato
anch'io all'inizio cioè come taxi fatta
a metterla lì e capire che cosa copre
degli attacchi aerei
no non è vero
[Applauso]
[Risate]
bellissimo quanto 706 permanenti no
sarebbe stato bellissimo per la legna ma
fai la spesa anche al forme stabilite
unita questa cazzo descritto pronto per
it it è in arrivo ordinato hamburger su
20 euro da hamburger arrivo subito
signora oddio è sparita slitta 500 euro
di slitta e cose che serve a legna
allora andiamo a far servizio a
domicilio per la legna caduta a micidio
nostro addio e cessare la caverna
cavernetta arrivo sto scendere giù del
patto che tu sei morto abbiamo ci vedo
morto zio è morto morto c'è il simbolo
del morto e perché sono stanco io sento
le orecchie o non è che sento di prima
no guarda sotto che c'è una donna con le
48 milioni le gambe allora il punto di
prima dove siamo morti prima dai eravamo
quasi voleva scappiamo da quadri erano
morti qua porca [ __ ]
ma dai non ci voglio credere dovevamo sì
ma non è vero
ora dove adesso sappiamo come un mazza
successo e adesso recuperiamo io dico
che sono i bambini morti sopra sua
risalito a 16 alicia gara in mano kakà
addosso io vedo se riesco a recuperare
la roba lì prima e poi corrono sudano ci
credo come fa sta matta thaci è tanto
sembrato c'è un cazzo se muoio
rispondono ma non è che ce ne sta più di
una aspetta che esce ne sta più di una
sicura si aspetta un attimo che recupera
che cosa è prima serie pro b ci sono ci
sono ci sono prese l'ho presa e l'ho
preso e mi ha preso al culo anche la
tipa barca travagliata star manara vengo
giù col tronchetto io ho recupera tutte
le cose che avevi tipo un vassoio
madonna vanta roba ho recuperato tutto
anche la scelta non grandissimo per te
vengo a fare stati fa e che con le gambe
redatto la non si leva in fretta o esco
io vieni dumas fanno in fretta la che
sta quindi in tavola scendendo a
scendere a lograto ci avevi un clock
facevo la molla che facevo come
esplodere anche la zia però bravo
possono c'è la moto va dall'alto bravo
bravo correte vedo e mi vedi però io non
posso arrivare lì che celati parte ci
sono i bambini monkey che sa come vedi
come cammina questo io vorrei salire
troppo ora che cinque o dio
i bambini che saltano attento
un bambino senza il panno lo sa che
schifo e lo vedi ma ancora la testa di
odio
oddio ma si lancia così usciamo che sta
morire usciamo veloce veloce ritirata
più aperto il cazzo ritirata la lancia i
bambini come se sale e cio che io sto a
1 de vita non sono anche come faccio a
essere vivo impossibile che comunque
fanno lo stesso suono dei nas cool è
uscito non ci posso credere mai non ci
posso credere mai che sono riuscito a
recuperare tutto sto uscendo con calma
eccomi qua aspetta che effetto ti non si
sa se io tifo salto d'acqua voi no non
lo fare zio non lo fa guarda cammino è
vero c'è ragione io oddio a vedere però
c'era guarda guarda a dio guarda le
butto giù pure starebbero male detto zio
e grossissimo vabbè dai faccio che
presenta a casa e grosso zio di scassa
tu devi riuscire a bloccarlo e come
calzini come faccio come fai a bloccare
addio adiacenti
no ma via
ma non è successo un pene addio ma che
cazzo mi è caduto in testa tagliata si
passa sotto che trasgrediranno siamo
sotto gli alberi che capo dio che sono
stato paziente la trappola non hanno
tanto nella trappola youtube ragazzi
fatto ha fatto il secondo sei solo tu
zio le leggi su ragazzi che cazzo è
perché ha scatenato in bocca
praticamente dobbiamo dobbiamo fare una
cosa loro
guarda che bello nuovo no vabbè zio a
quello no che fighissimo sta cosa si
apre si guarda con sé che può entrare
con la macchina compatto a chiuderlo con
la tesi che vuoi chiudere per il bellico
io no va bene che questa guerra ha mai
visto che salvo c'è un naso poi tanto
giovani a comportarsi
ed è qui ragazzi che sto per attuare il
mio piano malvagissimi mentre leonardo
intento a tagliare legna sono andato in
un villaggio di indigeni cercando di
attirarli verso di lui è una bottiglia
devo ecco che arriva il sì sì ci
dobbiamo mettere un pò cade odio cade
sul troppo dio ma [ __ ] ha preso in
pieno
sei morto addio chiudo il cancello il
nero che anzi non si chiude si e non si
aiuta addestrati e [ __ ] sono morto
guarda stich essi maledetti è andato in
fiamme voleva stremati zoccole ma sono
ancora lì a sia ancora lizzy io non ho
niente ci fu un cazzotto in bocca sto
bastardo e mai non possono anche quei
pugni non mi far fare ai morti non
possiamo mandarli via in qualche modo di
poco i totem da casa non è bella siamo
in casa a quest'altra sull'albero non è
anche sull'altro vai vai vai vai vai e
io no io lo sono ancora di marca merda e
non è stato ancora la casa non è no ma
come far prendere attimo lancia ma
possono arrivare
addio sono tutti i quali uniti non hanno
mai così raggiunto che culo a sul
proprio sotto è salve poi non abbiano
mangia possiamo pagare gli in faccia che
quasi esatto decideremo con i nostri
stronzi
oddio questo sta chiudendo stanno
picchiando la sua lezione dove dio no
liferay si stanno picchiando da solisti
deficienti de merda sono in quattro si
sono visti dall'alto sia impoveriti
stimo
vabbè incredibile norcia oddio non sono
caduto sono caduto non fatta cadere stai
sai che salgono a farti lasciate fare
file gay sono riuscita a risalire
io non sono una [ __ ] di domanda è una
mazzata un'altra volta d'accordo ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio è stata una cosa
piccante
secondo me the forest giocato almeno in
due è una roba esagerata secondo me è
troppo figo se però vi sia piaciuto
spero vogliate altri episodi fatti e non
me ne frega un cazzo il registro uguale
però che vi dicevo 100 ma se ci fosse un
commento è un mi piace anche la passione
di facebook come livido ad ottenere
iscrizioni solisti di sky ci vediamo al
prossimo vinto dalle ragazze